The rumours... still haven't gone away.
I've learned more about humiliation
in the past few weeks
than I hoped I would in a lifetime.
You married a wild spirit.
Trying to tame them is no use.
I've been queen barely ten years.
And in that time...
I've had three Prime Ministers.
Not one has lasted the course.
I understand the Prime Minister's
resignation and all--
It's not just the Prime Minister.
And your mother, and your sister,
and your country...
The whole relentlessness of it all.
The fact it never stops,
not for a minute.
But is it not possible that
among all those problems...
there are some of us
who are there for you no matter what?
If only.